Caleb.
Forrest.
Congratulations.
You guys have made it
into the final round
of this competition.
Now we're sending you
back to your home forges
to recreate this iconic
weapon from history.
The sword of Goujian.
Good luck, bladesmiths.
We will see you in four days.
Don't worry, man.
Congratulations.
We're going to take on
the sword of Goujian today.
I'm gonna started at the
tip, work back to the tang.
I'm keeping the blade
rather thick, because I just
don't want to mess
with any twisting
and bending once it quenches.
I am surprised how fast
this is coming along.
So far, so good.
Now it's time to get the
blade hot so I can quench it.
I'm happy.
I think we have a little
work in it here and there,
but nothing the grinder
won't take care of.
Today, I have to get
started on my sword.
I'm bringing these new school
vibes to this really old school
weapon.
Instead of bronze, I'm
bringing Damascus to the table.
Hopefully, this
will just give me
a really, really cool
contrast with the pattern
whenever I'm done with it.
All the welds are set good.
I'm getting the
metal drawn out good.
A nice, square bar.
And from there, I'm trying
to go for a twist pattern.
I want quite a few
good twists in there,
a pretty tight pattern.
All right.
That'll do.
The end of day one,
it's still not a weapon.
But it's getting there.
Today, I'm hoping to
have my guard fitted on.
Maybe even the handle.
For my guard, I'm going to
use a piece of angle iron.
The guard's around it, over now.
I'm just going to put a
hole through the bottom
just to go over the tang.
[groans]
The guard actually split.
Cracked.
All that fun for nothing.
So I have to start over.
I have a pile of
railroad spikes.
That would be putting the new
school into the bronze metal,
old school sword.
Fits on the tang really nice.
But there's more
work to be done.
The plan for today is
to get to work on actually
forging out the sword.
My goal for the
end of the day is
definitely to get it quenched.
This thing's getting long.
Just trying to keep it
where it's not too thin,
so that when I quench
it, everything goes well.
We're about ready.
I'm really just hoping that
nothing goes wrong here.
This is the most important
step of the entire process.
It's pretty straight.
Excited with the quench.
It went well.
Morning of day
3, and I'm tired.
First thing today, I'm going
to make my blade lighter.
Right now, the
balance is about five
inches in front of the guard.
I would like it to
be-- within an inch
or two would make me happy.
It's starting to feel lighter.
But I have a lot
more grinding to go.
OK.
I start grinding on my edge,
and my belt sander just quits.
Flip the breaker.
I'm not sure what
I'm going to do.
I've decided to go grab
two extension cords
and run power from
the house to the shop.
We got-- we got power
somewhere else we can use.
I plug the belt sander
into the house power.
And it works.
Hopefully, now I can get
the edge on the blade.
My blade's looking fine
and just needs a little
more sharpening and polishing.
Finally starting to see that
light at the end of the tunnel
now.
First thing, I'm going to
start on my disc pommel.
I'm just going to take
this piece of just normal,
mild steel, chop it off,
and kind of try to forge
it into a bit of a disc shape.
I'm kind of at a
square right now,
and I'm looking more
or less for a circle.
I'm just going to kind of
grind and polish off the top
and make it into a truer circle.
Time's running out.
I need to sharpen my blade,
and then finally finish
and put together the sword.
It's a little twisted.
The handle on the
blade is centered,
and it looks centered,
but on the inside,
as you can see right here,
it's not perfectly centered.
But of course, with
a pin and epoxy
and a disc and
scroll in the back,
it's going to be
very, very strong.
Forrest really better
bring it, because if not,
I'm going to chop him down.
Bladesmiths, welcome
to the kill test.
To find out what
kind of lethal damage
your weapon will do according
to its historic design,
I will take your
weapon and deliver
some killing thrusts and blows
on this ballistics dummy.
Forrest, are you up for this?
Yes, sir.
Let's do this.
[dramatic music]
All right, Forrest.
Let's talk about
your weapon here.
And it's very forward heavy.
What makes it hard
to handle is the fact
that you have a very
skinny handle right here.
A lot of these movements,
your blade went up on contact
and was spinning in my hand.
I had to adjust several
times to make sure that I
stayed on the edge over here.
Now, the edge is sharp.
Once it makes contact and
you slash, it digs deep.
Overall, sir, it'll kill.
All right, Caleb.
You're up.
You ready?
Let's see it.
[dramatic music]
All right, Caleb.
First up, the blade in
itself, balance-wise, I
think you nailed it.
Now, your handle construction.
It's ovoid.
It's actually comfortable.
Because of the balance
and a very sharp edge,
all the cuts are
very, very deep.
Overall, sir, it'll kill.
Bladesmiths, welcome to the
strength test, the gong chop.
To test the strength and
durability of your edges,
as well as the
overall construction
of your swords of
Goujian, I'm going to be
chopping them into these gongs.
Forrest, you're up first.
You ready?
Yes, sir.
[dramatic music]
Well, Forrest, your sword did
take some damage on the edge.
There's some rolls sort
of crushed in right here.
Your handle is really small.
A bigger handle would've helped
me control this really well.
But all that being said, that
much damage in a big strength
test like this?
Well done.
Thank you.
All right, Caleb.
You're up.
You ready?
Heck yeah, man.
[dramatic music]
Well, Caleb.
You did a great job
with the Damascus.
I love to see this
kind of stuff.
It's beautiful.
Your blade is still straight,
true, and the weight on this
is phenomenal.
There is one big issue, though.
Your handle.
It's loose now.
Your handle is coming apart.
I can move it.
And the pommel is also loose.
If these were right and
tight and held in place,
then it tends to help everything
else stay where it is.
But just a little bit
of play in this guard
can send shockwaves
right down the handle.
But I've got to say,
that's one heck of a blade.
- Thank you.
- It's just--
Thank you.
You know, this handle that's
really causing the issue now.
Yes, sir.
So we've got a
pretty mobile opening.
Then it has a
corresponding split
on the back side of the handle.
Not only is it loose, but
the material that's loose
has sharp edges.
OK.
Yeah.
I mean, this would
require either taping
that up, or wearing a glove.
And now we're not testing
the same as the other one.
OK.
Ben?
Dave?
That one kills me.
Yeah.
Can't have it.
Doug?
I agree.
All right.
Now, we've
continued with blades
that had loose parts before.
We've continued with blades
that had split handles before.
Your handle has cracked.
However, the combination
of the two things
has made your blade unsafe
to continue with any testing.
And therefore, you cannot be
our "Forged in Fire" champion.
I'd like to invite you
to shake our hands,
shake your competitor's
hand, and then I have to ask
you to please leave the forge.
I can't blame the
judges' decision.
It's definitely unsafe
to use at this point,
but that's a good call.
If I could have
done it differently,
probably would have put a
pin or two in my handle.
Might not have looked
as good, but the use is
more important than the looks.
Thank you so much, Forrest.
I appreciate it.
I may not be the "Forged
in Fire" champion,
but man, I'm walking out of
here with my head held high,
and I'm proud.
Forrest, congratulations.
You are the "Forged
in Fire" champion,
and that is a title
that comes with a check
for $10,000, my friend.
Good job.
Come on forward.
I'm thrilled that
I'm the champion.
Hasn't even soaked in yet.
In the next day or two, I'll
really realize what's happened.
Being a "Forged
in Fire" champion
means that I've succeeded in
the goal that I wanted to reach.
This is for everyone at
home, and I'm coming home
a "Forged in Fire" champion.
Yee haw.